russia's small nukes are a big problem  and it explains russia has a ten to one  advantage  over the us in non-strategic  low-yield nuclear weapons what are  sometimes called tactical or battlefield  nukes  and this is actually an area of concern  there are some who are hearing about  this and saying well  it's good that russia doesn't actually  have or would would not use the big  nukes here but the way in which it could  be a strategic disadvantage is  because russia has those battlefield or  tactical nukes  and nato has a much smaller supply of  those  putin knows  nato can't really respond with those  particular types of nukes